welcome back to CBS this morning I'm
Tony Tecopa with Gayle King and Anthony
Mason and we begin with Americans voting
today in state and local elections all
around the country and we are less than
one year before the 2020 presidential
election on that subject there are still
concerns about foreign interference like
we saw in campaign 2016 the government
stopped election security official says
that the threat has not gone away only
on CBS this morning we met with Chris
Krebs he is the director of cyber
security and infrastructure security
agency that's part of the Department of
Homeland Security and it is in charge
with something very simple and very
important protecting your vote this is
the core of homeland security and
national security right now it cuts to
the heart of what America is you know
that's what I always say it's not just
that election security is national
security but fundamentally what we do
here in this agency is ensuring that
this experiment of our constitutional
republic it can't continue forward
election a group until recently Chris
Krebs was the head of cyber security
policy for Microsoft now he's the top US
official responsible for protecting the
vote and he does it as head of an agency
created after the 2016 election when
according to investigators Russian
agents breached voter databases in at
least two states in addition to hacking
and releasing emails from Democratic
officials the Russians will are
continuing to try to destabilize our
form of government and just our way of
life in general they want to undermine
democracy exactly and so that's kind of
our planning factor they're gonna be
back there trying to get into our heads
they're trying to hack our brain so to
speak and ultimately have us lose faith
in our processes this is our
collaboration space Krebs gave us rare
access to a classified area he calls the
watch floor where teams constantly
monitor for digital threats so on
Election Day 2020 what will this look
like we will have campaign officials we
will have state local partners in here
intelligence community Department of
Defense the Federal Bureau of
Investigations everybody will be in here
sharing information in real time right
now the scenario that worries krebs the
most is the so called ransomware attack
targeting election offices what if
somebody locked up over voter
registration day
debase a month in front of an election
okay what are our fallback position
you're gaming that out now absolutely
the Department of Homeland Security is
working with thousands of local
jurisdictions and all 50 states and one
of its top goals is making sure every
digital vote is backed up with an
old-fashioned paper record for the 2020
election I think we're looking at about
92 percent of the votes in America will
be cast associated with a paper ballot
not to be a cynic but 92 percent still
leaves millions of votes come back up
yeah that no that's absolutely correct
so that's why again I'll take every day
we have between now and then
2020 to continue improving security of
these systems out there as they secure
the machinery that supports our
elections I think it is critical that
they're also keeping an eye on the
information that drives them the feds
have worked with social media platforms
to counter misinformation and they've
published documents warning the public
in simple terms about foreign
interference it's textbook you know it's
identify the divisive issue get it out
there get people engaged and then really
start driving the wedge issues and
splitting people apart how do you deal
with a situation where the president in
the United States is himself tweeting
and retweeting conspiracy theories
potential misinformation in some cases
on verified accounts that Twitter later
takes down and in the case of his son
the mother report found that he
retweeted a Russian operative so what do
you do your mission to clean up
disinformation and misinformation online
when some of the figures promoting that
are tied to the president United States
or are the President himself yes so you
know the president has obviously a very
high profile Twitter Twitter presence we
operate at a different in a different
space at a different level we're in the
security space the president's Twitter
account and what he says stands on its
own what we need to be able to do is
provide every American you know a
foundation where they can discern on
their own whether that's legitimate or
not
so even though President Trump has
sometimes cast doubt on Russia's
interference in 2016 the Trump
administration the government writ large
is prepared for Russia North Korea China
Iran in 2020 look I've gotten all the
the direction from the White House I
need as far as I understand coming
straight from the Oval make sure that
election Security's priority and protect
the 2020 election very important work
although foreign hackers access some
election systems in 2016 no votes were
altered at least as far as we know and
we also asked Krebs if they might have
just been casing the joint to come back
in 2020 and cause real damage and he
says that's something he does worry
about but he worries about everything
yeah I got a lot worried that he says
the last 10 years of his life it's felt
like the hardest 10 years of his life
even those live in - yeah in the job but
one of the bits of good news is the
paper backups so if someone claims that
a machine was tampered with votes go
haywire you know all the battleground
states will have a paper backup he says
in 2020 so you'll be able to verify the
vote that's a big deal yeah but a point
that at that eight percent that's not
backed up is a significant number in a
close election yeah but everybody's
watching that's a good news that
everybody's watching everybody's paying
attention and certainly more to come on
this yeah indeed cBS This Morning Calm
has much more of our interview with
Chris crabs including his take on
Facebook and Twitter's efforts to fight
misinformation on those websites